36e tour des rondes de la martinique
n'aura pas lieu je crois que tout le
monde a bien compris
la raison et le temps qui courent nous
donne justement les onze d'avoir pris
cette décision même si elle n'était pas
évident pour nom déjà les mondes
dirigeants pour nous l'équipe de gestion
et puis pour la population de management
on imagine bien aussi la frustration des
violeurs tout était bien parti
nous avions deux belles saisons ouverte
tant en baby doll campagnols sur la
bible il ya eu quand même six coups sur
les huit qui ont été faites donc on a
quand même des livres une classe de
première à la yole thimoté
mais c'est dans les grandes gueules que
cela nous a la frustration était
beaucoup plus important que l'amertume
même la déception puisque nous avions
réalisé que quatre courses sur les dix
non moins de 50% du championnat et donc
au moment où nous avons dû trancher dû
arrêter il n'ya pas donc eu de champion
deux titres de champion et c'était
vraiment bien parti parce que il y avait
quatre ou cinq six halls de mémoire qui
pouvait encore prétendre à ce titre
même si on pouvait imaginer peut-être la
7ème et 8ème parce que on sait très bien
les conséquences que continue le cool et
ou alors un incident de course et une
disqualification
donc tout ça participe au succès des
courses au piment des cous et c'était le
cas sur ce championnat puisque l'une des
leaders avait eu un accrochage sur une
bouée à la première course
elle était en train d'essayer de revenir
à la première place mais ce temps ce
temps que nous avons
je dirais que c'est en gros mais en
profite pour justement se remettre en
place un peu administrativement puisque
nous avons des points à améliorer sur
notre statut sur notre règlement
intérieur
même les règles de course il a quelques
modifications qui sont affairés qui ne
posait quelques problèmes lors des
courses donc on va essayer de réfléchir
à tout ça il soumet tout est sale à
l'assemblée et valider sa à la rentrée
prochaine si dieu donc nous sommes
entrés de se mettre un peu à jour vidéo
sur ce règlement et règles de course
à quand la reprise justement vous parlez
de la rentrée à caen dans les specs la
martinique va bien passer ce cap des
vacances et qu'on n'aura pas plus que ce
qu'on a là aujourd'hui
voire même rien du tout ce serait le top
et on peut voir et à ce moment là notre
reprise pour la fin octobre début
novembre
maintenant il faut très très très
prudent les deux sections section
bagnols des sections vol et petit bébé
hall en tout cas les deux responsables
locaux et sont en train de travailler
sur ce début de saison et on espère
pouvoir démarrer cette saison avec quand
même deux trois grands événements pour
la saison 2011 2021